quiero empezar por expresar
desde el corazón de la comisión de la
verdad
nuestro abrazo a todas las mujeres
hombres niños
ancianos
personas lgtb más
víctimas en colombia en todas partes a
nuestros hermanos indígenas afros ron a
nuestros hermanos rice a liszt
porque ustedes estamos aquí y por eso
nuestro primer saludo y nuestra
expresión de corazón es para todas y
todos ustedes
ya
pasado el protocolo que lo hizo
marta
quiero decirles que invitamos al
presidente iván duque
primero a que estuviera aquí presente y
luego a que a principios de la mañana de
hoy fue el primero en recibir como
presidente de la república el informe de
la comisión
no estuvo presente
salió el país se excusó y con nosotros
está representando le el ministro del
interior
danielle palacios a quien agradezco su
presencia
agradecemos
agradecemos la presencia del presidente
electo gustavo petro
[Aplausos]
punto
y la presencia de la vicepresidenta
francia márquez
[Aplausos]
traemos un mensaje de esperanza y futuro
para nuestra nación vulnerada y rota
verdades incómodas que desafían nuestra
divinidad
un mensaje para todas y todos como seres
humanos más allá de las opciones
políticas de las culturas y las
creencias religiosas
de las etnias y de los géneros
traemos una palabra que viene de
escuchar y sentir a las víctimas en gran
parte del territorio y en el exilio
de oír a quienes luchan por mantener la
memoria y resistir al negacionismo ya
quienes han aceptado
responsabilidades éticas políticas y
penales
un mensaje de verdad para detener la
tragedia intolerable de un conflicto en
que el 80% de las víctimas eran civiles
no combatientes
lo hacemos a partir de la pregunta que
ha cuestionado la humanidad desde los
primeros tiempos
dónde está tu hermano
y desde el reclamo de justicia que desde
el misterio sigue resonando en la
historia la sangre de tu hermano clama
justicia desde tu tierra
llamamos a sanar el cuerpo físico y
simbólico
pluricultural y pluriétnico que formamos
como ciudadanos y ciudadanas en esta
nación
el cuerpo que no puede sobrevivir con el
corazón infartado en el choco
los brazos gangrenados y en arauca las
piernas destruidas en mapiripán la
cabeza cortada en el salado la vagina
vulnerada en tierralta
las cuencas de los ojos vacías en el
cauca en el estómago reventado en tu
marco las vertebras trituradas en
guaviare los hombros despedazados en el
lugar el cuello degollado en el
catatumbo
el rostro quemado en machuca los
pulmones perforados en las montañas de
antioquia y el alma indígena arrasada en
el vaupés
llamamos a liberar nuestro cuerpo
simbólico y cultural de las trampas del
temor las iras las estigmatizaciones y
las desconfianzas
a sacar las armas del espacio venerable
de lo público a tomar distancia de los
que meten fusiles en la política
a no colaborar con los mesías que
pretenden apoyar la lucha legítima con
ametralladoras
convocamos a proteger los derechos
humanos y poner las instituciones al
servicio de la dignidad de cada persona
las comunidades y los pueblos étnicos
llamamos a tomar confianza de nuestra
forma de ver el mundo y relacionarnos
que está atrapada en un modo de guerra
en la que no podemos concebir que los
demás piensen distinto
hasta hacerlos enemigos y posibilitar
que algunos fueran convertidos en uno en
las chimeneas del horno crematorio
de juan frío
el que los soldados vinieran trofeos de
caza para la guerrilla y encontráramos
en bolsas de basura despojos de
políticos o baleados
que nos acostumbramos a la muerte y
suspendía en el secuestro
ya recoger diariamente cadáveres de
líderes incómodos
llamamos a aceptar responsabilidades
éticas y políticas
con sinceridad del corazón hemos
constatado que quienes reconocen
responsabilidades lejos de disminuir y
de disminuir su reputación la grandeza
porque pasan de ser parte
del problema a ser parte de la solución
que necesitan las víctimas y necesitan
ellos mismos
esta nación tiene la riqueza la riqueza
conmovedora de su pueblo
la multiplicidad de sus expresiones
culturales
la profundidad de sus tradiciones
espirituales y la tenacidad laboral y
empresarial
para producir condiciones que satisfagan
la vida anhelada tiene la felicidad
salvaje de su ecología
la potencia natural de sus océanos y
miles de ríos montañas y valles la
audacia de su juventud el coraje de las
mujeres
y fuerza secular de los indígenas los
campesinos los negros afrocolombianos
raizales
palenqueros y los ron
al mismo tiempo paradójicamente es una
sociedad excluyente
con problemas estructurales nunca
enfrentados con la voluntad política y
la grandeza ética que era indispensable
la inequidad el racismo el trato
colonial el patriarcado la corrupción el
narcotráfico la impunidad el
negacionismo la seguridad que no daba
seguridad
esto es precisamente lo que hay que
cambiar por caminos pacíficos y
democráticos
de lo contrario las maravillas de
colombia continuarán flotando sobre una
de las crisis humanitarias más brutales
del planeta
estamos convencidos de que hay un futuro
para construir
juntos en medio de nuestras legítimas
diferencias
no podemos aceptar la alternativa de
seguir acumulando
vidas despedazadas
desaparecidas excluidas y exiliadas
no podemos postergar el día en que la
capacidad definitivamente un deber y un
derecho y obligatorio cumplimiento
fuimos 11 los comisionados y
comisionados nombrados nombrados por el
comité de escogencia que estableció el
acuerdo de paz
venimos del acompañamiento a comunidades
y víctimas y procesos sociales y
culturales y debemos nuestro origen al
coraje de estos grupos que forman el
movimiento de la paz los derechos
humanos y la reconciliación
somos una de las tres entidades que
forman el sistema de verdad justicia
y reparación y agradecemos aquí la
presencia de la jurisdicción especial
para la paz
y de la unidad para encontrar a las
personas desaparecidas
dedicados a este esfuerzo murieron
nuestros compañeros comisionados alfredo
molano molano y ángela salazar
alfredo que hasta su último día anduvo
ríos caminos y páramos en la pasión por
los campesinos
y ángela que gastó su fuerza y alegría
al lado de las comunidades hasta que una
noche de urabá el cob y no la arrebato
siguiendo el reglamento elegimos a
quienes tomaron el relevo de nuestros
amigos
dos meses antes de concluir el informe
final un comisionado carlos guillermo
espina decidió retirarse
durante más de tres años como se ha
escuchado hemos oído a más de 30 mil
víctimas en encuentros personales y
colectivos en las casas de la verdad en
el exilio
y particularmente a las comunidades
afrocolombianas
indígenas en las
compañías gitanos
y entre los rallies
hemos estado en más de 24 países en el
exilio en los núcleos 12
y hemos recibido como se dijo también
más de 1000 informes hemos escuchado a
todos los ex presidentes de la república
vivos ernesto samper juan manuel santos
césar gaviria andrés pastrana y álvaro
uribe
así como intelectuales periodistas
artistas políticos obispos sacerdotes y
pastores
y nos hemos reunido muchas veces con las
fuerzas militares
que con el liderazgo del general javier
ayala aquí presentes aquí presentes
como comandante el comando conjunto de
transición
dirigió la contribución a la verdad de
las difíciles distintas instancias de la
fuerza pública
hemos escuchado a comparecientes ante la
jec y tenido reuniones y actos de
reconocimiento con los ex combatientes
de las farc
los miembros del partido comunes ex
integrantes de las demás guerrillas los
ex paramilitares del pacto de ralito y
otros responsables que están en las
cárceles
la corte constitucional prolongó por
siete meses nuestra vigencia
en respuesta a la solicitud de las
víctimas y organizaciones de derechos
humanos para poder recuperar el tiempo
reducido por la pandemia
hemos tenido al apoyo del sistema de
naciones unidas y todas sus agencias del
secretario general de naciones unidas el
consejo de seguridad la misión de
verificación y el fondo multidonantes y
recibido el soporte claro y discreto del
papá francisco de eeuu con un site de
todos los países de américa y de japón
hemos contado con más de 200 altos
y en agencias bilaterales el
international center for transition a
justice y fundaciones privadas como
porticus for open society y rockefeller
entre otras en el encuentro con la
comunidad internacional que conoce de
guerras nos ha impresionado el aprecio
que dan al proceso de paz en colombia
como una de las noticias positivas en un
mundo en conflicto y como una de las
negociaciones más serias entre un estado
y una insurgencia poderosa
constatamos
la solidaridad con las víctimas y el
apoyo al proceso de paz de la comunidad
internacional frente a la indiferencia
de grandes sectores de nuestra sociedad
que parecen no tener conciencia del
sufrimiento de millones de compatriotas
por causa de la guerra
aunque hay nuevas formas del conflicto
armado
aunque hay zonas del país donde las
comunidades consideran que ahora la
inseguridad es peor somos conscientes de
que no estamos en los tiempos en que las
farc-ep
llegaron a controlar la iniciativa de la
confrontación
y cuando el paramilitarismo en el grado
mayor de terror
alcanzó a ser una alternativa a las
puertas del poder
tiempos en que las desapariciones y los
secuestros se contaban por centenas los
desplazamientos por cientos de miles y
todas las camas del hospital militar
estaban copadas por heridos de guerra
los ganados en el acuerdo de paz de
noviembre de 2016 es una realidad
nuestro pueblo conoció en el año 2017 17
el más tranquilo de los años vividos en
medio siglo
conoció lo que significa la paz y no va
a renunciar a ello
y si bien los planes de desarrollo con
enfoque territorial
pd se limitaron a proyectos
demostrativos validados y por la misión
de verificación de la onu
estos mismos y la elección al congreso
de las víctimas en las circunstancias
especiales de paz y finalmente la
elección de gustavo petro
muestran que vamos a ir más allá en la
paz hasta que amemos la vida como lo
hemos cantado en los territorios
recibimos la misión de esclarecer en
tres años y medio la verdad de este
conflicto armado de más de seis décadas
significaron las víctimas alcanzar
la convivencia en los territorios y
establecer caminos de no repetición
hicimos con decisión y en medio de
presiones
oposiciones riesgos y el cob y lo que
nos fue posible
hoy con esta declaración
y con este volumen
entregamos al país el resultado
con un fuerte final
con la entrega y durante los dos meses
en que debemos socializar los resultados
en la comunidad nacional e internacional
concluiremos los arreglos
institucionales para dejar en la
jurisdicción especial para la paz y en
el sistema
el archivo de derechos humanos y nuestro
sistema de información misional y 'una
transmedia digital accesible en sus
computadores y celulares desde cualquier
parte del mundo
y en la que quedan de manera pedagógica
y fácil las narrativas vídeos y
productos pedagógicos que construimos en
el cumplimiento de nuestra misión
dejamos este legado de verdad a la
sociedad colombiana la ponemos en manos
de másteres de 3000 organizaciones e
instituciones aliadas
tenemos confianza en que el presidente
gustavo petro y su vicepresidenta
francia márquez y la unidad social y
política
que él ha convocado incorporar a las
recomendaciones en el diálogo
democrático e institucional para hacer
los cambios necesarios
quede en marcha el comité de seguimiento
y monitoreo sobre las recomendaciones
formado por siete personas la mayoría
mujeres
elegidos por nosotros mismos en
cumplimiento del decreto 588
la comisión en miles de actos de diálogo
como se acaba de presentar
ha contribuido a hacer de la verdad un
derecho público y un acontecimiento
dentro y fuera del país
esto se constante se constata
en la disposición de las víctimas que
llegaron por miles
superando el miedo que aún se vive en
algunos territorios
en las palabras de aceptación de los
responsables y en actos de
reconocimiento en la generosidad de
pueblos que tras escucharlos acogieron a
los responsables
en los documentos entregados por
centenares de grupos en las
instituciones y empresas que nos
entregaron su visión sobre el conflicto
muestras del acontecimiento son también
las críticas
señalamientos
estigmatizaciones mentiras de ataques
que recibimos los miembros de la
comisión
la escucha de las víctimas nos han
acudido brutalmente ante las
kilométricas filas de niñas y niños
llevados a la guerra
la procesión interminable de buscadores
de compañeros e hijos desaparecidos
las fosas comunes y cadáveres de
muchachos y muchachas rurales
desperdigados en las montañas
muchos de ellos indígenas y
afrocolombianos las miles de mujeres
abusadas y humilladas los poblados
masacrados y abandonados
pudiera seguir con esto voy a referirme
a esto en la segunda parte pero déjenme
detenerme por ahora compartiendo las
preguntas que nos hemos hecho
porque el país no se detuvo para exigir
a las guerrillas y al estado para la
guerra política desde temprano y
negociar desde el principio una paz
integral cuál fue el estado y las
instituciones que no impidieron y más
bien promovieron el conflicto armado
donde estaba el congreso
donde los partidos políticos
hasta donde los que tomaron las armas
contra el estado calcularon las
consecuencias brutales y macabras de su
decisión
nunca entendieron que el orden armado
que imponían sobre los pueblos y
comunidades
que decían protegerlo las destruían y
las dejaba después en manos de los
paramilitares que llegaban a acabar las
que hicieron ante esta crisis del
espíritu los líderes religiosos
y aparte de los pastores y mujeres de fe
de que incluso pusieron la vida para
acompañar y denunciar que hicieron otros
sacerdotes y obispos y comunidades
religiosas y ministros
qué hicieron los educadores
qué dicen los jueces y fiscales que
dejaron acumular la impunidad
qué papel jugaron los formadores de
opinión y los medios de comunicación
como nos atrevimos
y dejar que pasara
y cómo nos podemos atrever a permitir
que continúe
[Aplausos]